Marc Kromer ist Grafikdesigner.
Seine Freizeit verbringt er
am liebsten in der Küche. Er schreibt
den Blog „Bake to the roots“
und diese Seite wurde schon mehrfach
in Deutschland prämiert.
Dahinter verbirgt sich ein wahres
Hüftgoldparadies. Von der
Zitronen-Thymian-Tarte bis zum fruchtigen
Käsekuchen – wer sich durch Marc Kromers
Rezepte klickt, dem läuft schon beim
Lesen das Wasser im Mund zusammen.
Doch bevor die Rezepte online gehen,
muss Marc Kromer erst einmal
selbst an die Rührschüssel. Heute gibt es
etwas Hippes: ein Hybridtörtchen.
Cruffins, die sind einfach superlecker!
Das ist so ’ne Mischung aus
Croissant und Muffin. Nicht ganz so fettig,
aber genauso lecker … mindestens.
Seit vier Jahren schreibt Marc Kromer
seinen Blog. Als er anfing,
fürs Netz zu backen, hatte er nicht damit
gerechnet, über so lange Zeit
erfolgreich dabeizusein. Nun hat er auf
Instagram mehr als 33.000 Abonnenten.
Doch typisch deutsch backt er nicht.
Ich hab’ mal in den USA gelebt und
gearbeitet, hab’ mich da
in Cupcakes verliebt. Und die gab’s bei
uns damals hier in Deutschland noch nicht
und ich hab’ dann angefangen, die
Sachen selber zu backen zu Hause
und hatte immer so ’n bisschen Probleme
mit den Rezepten, weil’s verschiedene
Sachen nicht gab an Zutaten, und
hab’ dann Sachen ersetzt und
dann aufgeschrieben und
dacht’ mir irgendwann:
„Mh, könnte anderen Leuten genauso
gehen!“ – und hab’ dann angefangen
alles aufzuschreiben und [es]
irgendwann ins Internet gestellt.
Der Cruffinteig muss jetzt eine Weile
gehen. Zeit, um sich dem Blog zu widmen.
Viel Arbeit steckt darin – bis zu 16
Stunden verbringt er damit in der Woche.
Drei neue Rezepte stellt er dann online.
Aber nur, wenn sie seinen
Gaumentest bestanden haben.
Was macht er mit dem Rest?
… [ wird] meistens an meine
Kollegen verfüttert.
Der Teig ist so weit. Jetzt noch ausrollen,
mit Zimt und Zucker bestreuen
wieder einrollen, schneiden und ab
in die Förmchen damit!
Für 25 Minuten geht’s nun in den Ofen,
bei 200 Grad Celsius.
Ein spannender Moment, denn auch
den Besten gelingt nicht immer alles.
Ja, ich hab mal versucht,
Cookies ohne Mehl zu machen,
und das war einfach furchtbar!
Die sind zerbröselt ohne Ende
und deswegen werde ich nie
wieder ohne Mehl backen!
Bei den Cruffins läuft alles wie geplant.
Wenn sie aus dem Ofen kommen,
duftet der Raum nach Butter und Hefe.
Am besten sind sie lauwarm,
aber Marc Kromer kann noch nicht naschen
– schließlich müssen noch Fotos her.
Wie gesagt: Eine Menge Aufwand mit dem
Blog. Aber die Ideen gehen ihm nicht aus.
Als Nächstes [gibt‘s] Churro-Cups mit Eis.
Das sind solche kleinen …
kennt ihr vielleicht, so Churros aus
Spanien? Gibt’s normalerweise in langer
Form und ich habe Cups gemacht draus
und in die füllt man dann das Eis rein.
Was aus Marc Kromers Ofen kommt,
sieht nicht nur gut aus
– auch das Nachbacken lohnt sich!